Transcriptor: Silvia Solana
Revisor: Emely Mack
Ese es el tema principal
de la telenovela: Leonela.
Transmitida por Radio Caracas
Televisión en 1983.
Leonela es una joven
comprometida con Otto.
Otto le da una golpiza
a Pedro Luis, el protagonista,
y Pedro Luis en venganza
se viola a Leonela.
Obviamente, Leonela queda embarazada,
él va a la cárcel y cuando sale,
ella se enamora de su violador y se casan.
En términos de política,
sería como decir que llega un militar
y, a la fuerza, trata de tumbar
al gobierno electo,
y como no lo logra, va a la cárcel,
y cuando sale, el pueblo
le da su voto en elecciones,
y luego no importa lo que pase,
el pueblo lo idolatra por siempre.
Las historias que nos contamos
nos construyen.
No importa si son reales o ficticias.
Sólo importa cómo nos vinculamos
emocionalmente con estas historias,
y la frecuencia con la que las consumimos.
Imagínense el poder de una sola historia,
contada como si fuera un mantra,
día tras día,
durante décadas,
a toda una nación.
O incluso, a todo un continente.
Permítanme compartir con Uds.
el que considero un muy
representativo ejemplo de lo que es
"El poder de la ficción"
Desde hace casi 70 años, en Venezuela,
las familias tenían en la sala
de su casa un televisor;
y allí entraban principalmente dos canales
y en ambos se transmitía durante
varias horas del día: telenovelas.
Eso eran: dos telenovelas en el
almuerzo y dos telenovelas en la cena,
en la época en la que
se almorzaba y se cenaba.
Por muchos años fuimos
de los más grandes exportadores
de telenovelas del mundo,
y ese era un gran orgullo para el país.
Petróleo, misses y telenovelas.
Si querías ser actriz,
y además pagar tus cuentas
con tu carrera de actuación,
había que trabajar en algunas telenovelas.
"Mea Culpa”
Y, a decir verdad, no solamente era
muy entretenido grabar las escenas,
sino también muy gratificante
descubrir en carne propia cómo gran
parte del país e incluso en el extranjero,
adoraban estas novelas; y bueno,
también el trabajo de uno en ellas, ¿no?.
En la historia de la televisión venezolana
ha habido unas telenovelas más
interesantes y originales que otras,
pero el género más fuerte siempre ha sido:
la telenovela rosa
Esta es la sinopsis de la telenovela
rosa, contada una y otra vez:
La chica pobre, humilde, trabajadora,
que no tiene donde caerse muerta,
llamémosla Rubí,
tan linda, tan inocente y frágil.
Ella se enamora de un chico
honesto y buena gente,
que llamaremos Víctor Alfonso,
que resulta ser el hijo de una
millonaria maluquísima, la villana,
elegantísima y adineradísima,
que llamaremos Lucrecia.
Durante muchos episodios
Lucrecia y su séquito
maltratan a la pobre Rubí.
La engañan, la manipulan, la violan,
se burlan, la humillan...
Cada historia a lo suyo,
pero a la mitad de la telenovela,
hay una revelación:
hubo una herencia que fue
corrompida, usurpada,
no se le entregó a quien le correspondía,
a la chica pobre, a Rubí.
¡Ella era la verdadera heredera de
toda la fortuna de esa mansión!
Pero la malévola Lucrecia,
muy hijadeputamente, se la robó.
La historia avanza, hay un giro...
y Rubí, recupera milagrosamente
la herencia robada.
Y de un capítulo a otro,
simplemente cambiándole el peinado,
el maquillaje, el vestuario,
se vuelve de "alcurnia",
y ejerce la venganza contra la villana, y
contra todos los que se burlaron de ella.
La gente en su casa pegada al televisor,
con la boca llena de arepa,
como si se tratara de su propia vida
y le están hablando al espejo,
Gritaban: ¡Así es mijita! ¡Así es!
¡Bien hecho! ¡Ahora sí lo logró!
¡Ahora que pague esa!
¡Que sufra la malvada!
Cincuenta años de telenovela rosa,
sin siquiera imaginarlo,
prepararon el terreno
para que el discurso del teniente coronel
Hugo Rafael Chávez Frías,
calara profundamente en los venezolanos.
Porque la trama de estos culebrones
la volvíamos a consumir,
pero ahora en forma
de alocución presidencial,
también por varios años
y durante largas horas
en cadena nacional.
Esta vez, nos la contaban así:
la chica pobre, humilde, pata en el suelo,
llamémosla: el pueblo,
se enamora de un chico
honesto y buena gente,
que a efectos de estas latitudes,
llamaremos: el teniente coronel.
Y será él, quien se le volteará
a la mala millonaria, a la villana,
que llamaremos: la oligarquía.
Lo cierto es que surge una revelación:
La oligarquía le ha robado todo
lo que le pertenece al pueblo
quien era la verdadera heredera
de toda la fortuna de esta
mansión llamada: Venezuela.
Hay un giro.
Esta vez es el protagonista,
el teniente coronel,
quien se le voltea a la madre poderosa
y hace que la multimillonaria herencia
regrese a manos de la verdadera
heredera: el pueblo.
Lo truculento y malsano de esta historia
y de todas estas telenovelas,
es el hecho de que se le despierte
a Rubí, al pueblo,
la sed de venganza contra la oligarquía.
Despertada intencionalmente
por su amado teniente.
Y, con el paso del tiempo,
de discurso en discurso,
los villanos, “las Lucrecias”,
se fueron multiplicando,
porque se fue incluyendo allí
a prácticamente todo aquel
que tuviera un poquito más
que la chica pobre.
De hecho se llegó a un punto
en que “la villana” era
simplemente todo aquel
que no estuviera del lado
del chico honesto y buena gente,
el teniente coronel.
Y así, en esta versión,
la villana, la oligarquía,
se ha vuelto un gentío:
Es la clase alta y la clase media,
es la cuarta república, la oposición,
el "imperio", la Iglesia,
los medios de comunicación,
la empresa privada,
los inversionistas extranjeros,
los empleados petroleros, los sindicatos,
los profesores, los estudiantes.
Y así, cualquiera que
no sea la chica pobre
ni el teniente coronel.
Y no sé que pasa con
esta versión de la historia,
que no fueron felices para siempre.
Y es que claro,
el discurso de la revolución bolivariana,
al igual que la telenovela rosa
se disfrazaban de “amor”,
pero de lo que realmente hablaban
era de resentimiento,
de envidia, de rencor,
en definitiva, de odio.
Estas telenovelas "rosa",
se transmiten en Venezuela desde
la primera telenovela venezolana:
"La criada de la granja" en 1953.
Hasta incluso hoy,
que, aunque ya no se producen
telenovelas en Venezuela
por… "la situación",
se está transmitiendo en
horario estelar una bien “rosa”
grabada en Miami, llamada: "Acorralada".
Con su respectiva herencia robada
y su respectiva venganza.
Año 2020 y en televisión
abierta en Venezuela,
se siguen viendo: telenovelas rosa.
Claro, los días que hay electricidad.
Y entre esta primera y esta última,
hay un montón de exitosísimas telenovelas
que cumplen a cabalidad este patrón.
Sólo por mencionar algunas entre
mexicanas, mayameras y venezolanas, están:
"Rosa salvaje", "Gata salvaje",
"Corazón salvaje", "Corazón indomable",
"Alma indomable", "La indomable",
"Pobre diabla", "Cara sucia",
"El desprecio",
"Yo compro esa mujer",
"Valentina", "Carolina", "Sabrina",
"Rosalinda", "Marimar",
"Cristal", "Topacio",
"Esmeralda", "Rubí rebelde",
"Mi gorda bella",
"Las dos Dianas", "La italianita",
"La dama de rosa",
"La dueña", "La revancha",
"La venganza".
Siempre la misma historia:
la pobre, la rica, maltrato,
herencia, venganza…
La pobre, la rica, maltrato,
Cuando les preguntaban
a los gerentes de televisión
"¿Por qué siempre esa misma trama
con ese mensaje de venganza?”
“El conde de Montecristo,
un clásico de la literatura universal
al que le hacemos homenaje…”
¿Para qué harían falta tantos
homenajes para una sola historia, no?
Llegaban escritores con ganas
de contar algo nuevo:
¿Qué tal si hacemos una telenovela
de ruptura, diferente,
con un concepto más original,
que transmita valores?
Pero casi siempre, la respuesta era:
Noooo...Noo...Noo… Eso no sube cerro.
"Eso no sube cerro".
Con esta frase se referían
a que les era fundamental
ser sintonizados por las clases más bajas.
Y esa trama, siempre esa trama,
les había garantizado rating;
y con rating se aseguraban
a los anunciantes.
En Venezuela, había una eterna competencia
entre dos canales de televisión
y esa competencia definía la programación.
De vez en cuando, asumían el riesgo
y se salían de la fórmula;
a veces con éxitos fulgurantes,
pero otras veces con
fracasos estrepitosos,
así que siempre recurrían a la trama
que sabían que subiría cerro.
Con estas observaciones no
pretendo señalar a la televisión
como responsable de lo que
ha pasado en el país,
por supuesto que no.
Este es un elemento cultural
entre muchos factores.
Además, se trataba de empresas privadas
haciendo lo que consideraban
lo mejor para sus negocios,
siguiendo la tendencia de lo que
se producía y se consumía
en toda Latinoamérica;
y además, recibiendo el espaldarazo
del resto del planeta,
que compraba sus producciones.
Pero sí creo que hubo una gran
subestimación del alcance masivo,
y del poder formativo de estas
horas de ocio y entretenimiento.
Podríamos pensar
que las ficciones que creamos
son producto de la cultura que nos rodea,
pero acaso, ¿no será al revés?
¿No será que nuestra cultura
es el resultado
de estas historias que nos contamos?
Estoy segurísima de que habrán
millones y millones
de ejemplos como este,
en cada país, en cada pueblo,
de cómo ese rato de ocio
y entretenimiento diario,
nos definen profundamente
como individuos y como sociedad.
Estados Unidos, por ejemplo,
un país con cultura
de reality shows y celebrities,
bueno, escogieron de presidente
a un personaje que ha llevado
sus campañas y su gobierno,
como si se tratara de un reality show.
¿Qué tal si dejamos la política a un lado?
El caso del crecimiento exponencial
de nuevos estudiantes
en la carrera de paleontología,
al año siguiente del estreno
de Jurassic Park.
O aún más reciente,
en España, en el 2018,
hubo un incremento de estudiantes,
esta vez de “filosofía”,
y todo señala a la buena influencia
de la serie catalana “Merlí”,
que trata sobre la relación de un
profesor de filosofía con sus estudiantes.
Somos lo que consumimos
para bien y para mal.
Es por eso que es fundamental reconocer
el poder de las historias
que nos contamos.
El poder de la ficción.
Habría que preguntarnos,
como espectadores,
¿qué estamos consumiendo constantemente?
¿Qué programas vemos?
¿A quiénes seguimos en redes sociales?
¿En qué ponemos nuestra atención
justo cuando estamos relajados?
Cuando bajamos la guardia.
Y para los que de alguna forma
contamos historias
que hoy en día con las nuevas tecnologías,
somos prácticamente todos.
Imaginemos:
¿Qué cuento podríamos
echarnos, miles de veces,
de ahora en adelante,
para que el mundo sea mejor?
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)